hello i'm alvin welcome back to tasties
making big the show where i make giant
versions of some of america's most
beloved foods
today i'm gonna be making a giant oreo
why i love oreos let's get going
[Music]
boom okay so this is an oreo
do you guys see a problem because i do
it's small
and we don't do that here i'll save you
for later so to start i'm going to sift
dry ingredients
into a bowl this is flour baking
soda salt dutch processed cocoa powder
this is the special dark cocoa powder
that gives the oreo its signature color
little whisk that looks cool
right dry ingredients are set i'm going
to cream
the butter and the sugar in my trusty
little kitchenaid
his name is todd put in a lot of work
last season
whoa whoa whoa calm down now came back
from the dead
here we go
i'm gonna say that's good now four eggs
back on we go oh it's dark
when i look into it i can't see anything
it's like looking into a black hole
and we're done oh wait
it's not cooked maybe i shouldn't have
done that
looks like something from a volcano
that's nice look at that it's so soft
[Music]
oh this is not shaping just like the
circle i wanted it to
now we're gonna get this onto a tray the
question is
how do we get this onto this
the answer i i don't know
i think it's sticking to the table a
little bit
[Music]
oh it's starting to break a little bit
well this oreo is very interesting
hold on i got it oh it looks like we're
going to flip it over
and i dropped the dough good job alvin
we'll be right back
so this is some dough that we re-rolled
using the scraps
and i'm going to start cutting shapes
because
a regular oreos design is actually very
very very complex a lot of triangles
lines circles i'm starting with a square
down you go
nice this is very fun it reminds me of
arts and crafts class that i did very
poorly at
i'm going to cut these into triangles so
i'm going to go halfway good job alvin
thanks now i'm going to cut some circles
this guy oh how do i get you out
good oh oh ignore the hole in the back
i'm gonna be here for a while i think
i'm just gonna cut out my own name
so we have little letters i'm going to
start from the back
and oh god come on come out
i should have flowered it all right
alvin what are you doing
that's a little ugly i want to do that
again
we're gonna flower this time like smart
people
all right come out oh well
we're gonna give this one more try ah
yes that's an n
great how do you get this a out what
yeah saying it chief hey yo
this is a terrible a yeah i'm gonna i
think i'm just gonna hand cut this a
okay i might have made the legs a little
too long that's okay
this is alvin but a is bold
while those shapes are chilling in the
fridge we actually have two
of these dough circles culinary helped
me make another one so again
thank you guys because an oreo has that
ring on the outside
and i want to see if i can get that
design too center
please be center now we can cut a ring
around
that is a lot stiffer than i thought it
was gonna be
nice i'm gonna save this for later so
this is a little ring
and this guy goes on this guy kind of
like
making dumplings you gotta wet the edges
a little bit so it sticks
so ancient chinese technique passed down
from generation to generation
[Music]
oh god is it gonna break oh
don't break it broke that's okay that's
just how it goes sometimes
one two and we go around
that looks pretty cool all right now we
gotta get this guy back onto the tray
[Music]
here we go i'm going to use this ring to
shape him up
a little better looking great feeling
great
clear hearts cold mines can't lose
nope that's not how it goes at all all
right
the outer ring is done let's see if i
know how to spell
oh god that's not centered is it oh
let's highlight this oh i like that
one two one two oh that looks like a
clock
now let's get these wedges on
now that looks cool all right
i think
i think this is it i'm just gonna for
safety put this guy
in the freezer and then i'm gonna bake
him i'll see you guys after i take a
little nap
oh good oreo time to make the frosting
apparently there's a lot of stuff that
goes into it we found a recipe which is
actually made by buzzfeed alumni scott
leuch
and we scaled it up we scaled it up a
lot eight sticks
of butter and we're gonna cream it
wow it smells so good oh my god
and this is clear vanilla extract
i don't know where this comes from but
it smells
like rainbow so we're gonna put it in
this
is eight cups of powdered sugar
another egg cups oh god look what you
did alvin you messed it up again you
doofus oh jesus oh jeez it's spilling
again
come on alvin oh god oh jesus
get back in there no don't come out
it's kind of looking like frosting wow
that's stiff
jesus okay frosting is done i'm going to
get it
into this bowl oh my god i made it
like a sugar crime scene over here don't
tell the police
oh my god this is your brain on drugs
nope i should not say that this is a
family-friendly show
that's for making a big after dark
probably wallpaper my house with this
if i if i had a house i can't i can't
afford a house
the top of the cookie is in the oven
it's gonna bake for a little bit it's
gonna chill
now we have the bottom which has been
baked off and
we have all this amazing frosting
that we made so i think it'll be fun to
use
an ice cream scoop ooh that's nice
i like that very much this is like
building a sundae
but it's not ice cream it's just butter
i feel like each one of these scoops
has enough filling to almost like
fill a whole sleeve of oreos i'm pretty
sure this is not how they make
oreos back at the factory smoosh them
all together so they become good friends
look at this look at this this is a
smooth
oreo so this is
my oreo that i baked and the goal is to
get it onto here
not sure if i'm going to be able to get
this but we will do our best
this is an interesting problem
how do i get you on there
it's not coming off oh there it is
[Music]
all right okay
that's on it's it's me
in an oreo i heard that our culinary
team wonderful people in the back
have actually been making more of these
so
you know as oreo is proud to say they
are
milk's favorite cookie so we have a nice
giant glass of milk
look at this it's like 10 pounds holy
moly
this giant oreo is at least
a hundred times the size of a normal
oreo
i very happy with this let's eat it
this is one thick cookie oh
it's like trying to get excalibur out of
the ground
would you look at that this is my oreo
sandwich
whoa this tastes like an actual oreo it
has that crumbliness when you dip it in
the milk
oh that feeling is thick my heart is
beating very fast
well if you excuse me i have a lot of
oreos to eat
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you